MUELLER INVESTIGATION, HOW IT
STARTED, WHERE IT IS RIGHT NOW
AND POSSIBLY WHERE IT IS GOING.
>> ON TWITTER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WELCOMES OF THE COUNTRY INTO THE
SECOND YEAR OF WHAT HE CALLS
"THE GREATEST WITCH HUNT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY" ADDING, THERE
IS STILL NO COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA, ONLY COLLUSION BY
DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER WENT
FURTHER.
WE ARE CHALLENGING THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
MAYBE A SPECIAL COUNSEL SHOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN APPOINTED BASED
ON AN ILLEGAL LEAK.
>> ONE YEAR INTO THE PROBE, NEW
DETAILS EMERGED ABOUT ITS ORIGIN
IN THE SUMMER OF 2016 AND A
MAJOR PIVOT BY THE FBI.
>> WE CANNOT FIND A CASE THAT
WOULD SUPPORT BRINGING CRIMINAL
CHARGES ON THESE FACTS.
>> THREE WEEKS AFTER THAT EMAIL
ANNOUNCEMENT, THEY LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION CODENAMED
"CROSS FIRE HURRICANE."
BY EARLY AUGUST 2016, ACCORDING
TO TEXT MESSAGES, FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK LATER REMOVED FROM
THE CASE WENT TO THE
U.S. EMBASSY IN LONDON AND
INTERVIEWED A KEY WITNESS.
AN INVESTIGATIVE SOURCE
CONFIRMED TO FOX DETAILS FIRST
REPORTED BY THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
THE FBI FIRST OBTAINED PHONE
RECORDS AND OTHER DOCUMENTS
USING SECRET NATIONAL SECURITY
SUBPOENAS.
THE TIMES THAT THERE WAS AT
LEAST ONE INFORMANT, AND THE
PRESIDENT CLAIMED IN ANOTHER
TWEET THAT THE OBAMA FBI SPIED
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, AND SAID,
IF TRUE, IT'S BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
>> I HAVEN'T SPOKEN WITH HIM
DIRECTLY ABOUT THAT, BUT I'VE
CERTAINLY SEEN THE REPORTS.
IF THERE IS ANY TRUTH TO THAT,
IT SHOULD CERTAINLY BE LOOKED
INTO.
>> BY AUGUST 2016, JOHN BRENNAN
BRIEFED THEN FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY AS WELL AS THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER HARRY REID.
THIS LETTER FROM RITA BECAME ONE
OF THE FIRST PUBLIC
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS OF THE SECRET
RUSSIA PROBE.
IN OCTOBER, THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OBTAINED THE FIRST
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT FROM TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AIDE CARTER PAGE.
IT WAS THE SO-CALLED TRUMP
DOSSIER.
TWO YEARS SINCE THE FBI OPENED
ITS INVESTIGATION, THE